nothing is left to chance when
protecting the president a massive
security operation began in the hours
before his arrival from the home of the
US ambassador where he will stay to the
central London locations he visits many
roads were closed to vehicles but some
of those involved didn't need to worry
about traffic on the ground the ring of
steel around mr. Trump extended to the
gates of Buckingham Palace visitors are
normally allowed up close even when the
Queen is at home but not when she is
hosting the president we're here to
protest not to welcome him Donald Trump
has made some very bad choices
campaigners couldn't resist a visual
display should the president casually
look out of the window of his helicopter
but today's main anti Trump weapon was
rather civilized a boycott of the state
banquet by a handful of politicians I
suspect that most British people don't
like him being here I mean it's not just
that he's a nasty piece of work I mean
he is but the D is actually undermining
Britain's interests that this is the
crux of it from my point of view bigger
louder protests are planned for Tuesday
but this was a small foretaste of what's
expected you can argue that
demonstrations are futile even juvenile
but they are having an impact on this
visit because the prospect of the
president being jeered rather than
cheered meant he was denied an
opportunity bestowed
previously on other controversial world
leaders
frosted relations with Russia mean
Vladimir Putin is unlikely to take this
journey ever again but he did in 2003
others who've enjoyed the carriage ride
alongside the Queen include the late
king of Saudi Arabia and the current
Chinese president the need to do
business with Xi Jinping trumped
concerns over human rights instead mr.
Trump's motorcade took a rather lonely
drive down a mall
deserted apart from the police and the
media when his route did take him close
to the public it was mostly curious
Londoners and tourists rather than noisy
activists previous presidential tours
have seen social visits to pubs plus
some friendly sporting competition
pictures which accentuate the closeness
of the anglo-american alliance the US
may still be our closest ally but rarely
has there been such disharmony in
transatlantic relations in Woods Sky
News central London